[موسيقى]
سلسلة جبال فارونجا في شرق إفريقيا
مذهلة وجميلة
وتضم واحدة من أكثر الموائل تنوعًا
في القارة ، حيث يمكنك العثور
على
الملوك الحقيقيين للغابة أكثر من نصف
سكان العالم
من الغوريلا الجبلية المهددة بالانقراض
هنا وأنا '  لقد أتيت لمقابلة عدد قليل منهم
معقمًا على النحو الواجب وجاهزًا
لبدء التسلق إلى الغوريلا ، وعلينا
ارتداء أقنعة
طوال الوقت ، من الواضح أن هذا لحماية
أنفسنا ولكن
الأهم من ذلك حماية الغوريلا
منا
تمامًا بمجرد أن
نتشارك نحن البشر 98 من  الحمض النووي الخاص بنا
مع الغوريلا ، فهذا يعني أن الفيروس التاجي
قد يكون ضارًا لهم تمامًا
مثلنا حتى قبل أن تعاني غوريلا كوفيد
من
التهابات في الجهاز التنفسي ، وقد أكدنا أن
بعض هؤلاء كانوا من البشر
ولكنهم أكثر عرضة
لأنشطتنا نظرًا لأنهم قريبون
منا
يمكننا نقل المرض إليهم ، فإن
أمراضنا مميتة للغاية
عندما يصلون إلى مجتمعاتهم.دكتور
نويل جان بوسكو
يعمل لدى أطباء الغوريلا  فريق من
طبيبًا بيطريًا في المنطقة مرضاه
كانوا أكثر عرضة للإصابة بالأمراض البشرية
لأكثر من قرن منذ
التوسع
في الزراعة في المنطقة ، كانت هذه
القابلية للإصابة بأمراضنا
جنبًا إلى جنب مع الصيد التاريخي
للمقاتلين كارثية على السكان عام 1933
فيلم king kong الذي بدأ فيه المرء
المزيد من تصاريح شراء الصيد
والخروج وصيد الغوريلا
إذا قتلت واحدًا ، فأنت أعني أنك
غير عادي ، وهذا ما حدث
مما أدى إلى انخفاض كبير في
التطبيقات الحمراء
في الثمانينيات كان عددها أقل  من
250. بفضل عمل دكتور
نيرل وفريقه وجهود الحفظ
اليوم ، هناك أكثر من ألف
منهم
يقدمون الأدوية ويقومون بإجراء
العمليات
الجراحية بالطبع هي تجربة حقيقية على الحالات التي
يصل وزنها إلى 500 رطل
فهي ثقيلة جدًا.  أقوياء ، لا يتعين
علينا عادةً حمل هذا
القدر الضخم من الشظية من مكان إلى
مكان آخر
لأن مستشفانا يقع في
الغابة مباشرةً  لذلك نحن نفعل كل شيء هناك ، أصبح
الصيد غير قانوني الآن في الحدائق ،
لكنه لا يزال يمثل مشكلة كبيرة حتى بالنسبة
لأصغر المجموعة
مثل هذا الرضيع الذي تم القبض على يده
في شرك صياد غير
قانوني إذا لم تتدخل في غضون الوقت
الذي سيموت فيه هذا الحيوان أو يخسر  تعتمد يد
الطعام على المكان الذي يتم فيه
تحرير الفخ وإعادته بأمان إلى
المجموعة
كان تسليط الضوء على مهنة الدكتور
نويل ، والشعور الجيد أنك تحدث
فرقًا ، إنه أمر فريد جدًا ، حيث
ترى مقدار مساهمتك في الأم
باستخدام الطب البيطري  العلم لاستعادة
السكان ، إنه حقًا
أبعد من الخيال تشعر أنك على ما يرام
أنا
هناك بالنسبة لي ، فأنا أراقب هذه المخلوقات المعجزة
القريبة جدًا منا ومهددة جدًا
بما نقوم به ،
ومن الصعب التعبير عن مدى
روعة التواجد في وجودهم و  مشاهدة
التفاعل في
محاولة لمعرفة ما يحدث
بين
الحقائب الفضية
والسوداء والأطفال والديناميكيات الأبدية الخشنة والمتقلبة
ثم يتجولون في
الأوراق  نتساءل جيدًا عن سبب كل شيء
[الموسيقى]